make it about you not like you're
sticking up for the guy yeah you make it
about you like that makes me
uncomfortable right when you say mean
[ __ ] to
tom or john charisma whatever the [ __ ]
[ __ ] i was gonna say that great good job
uh dave
and
if if you talk to john charisma that way
when i'm around it makes me
uncomfortable steve windheimer if you
talk to steve wintheimer yeah stephen
pinker okay whatever it is you know who
is it uh he's a making it i don't know
if he's a psychologist or a sociologist
but he's he's famous for okay well go
ahead
he wrote he wrote books uh
better angels what is that what is the
name of that book makko
uh he writes about how the world is in
fact not being becoming a worse place
it's becoming a better safer cleaner
more healthy
uh place than it actually has ever been
consistently year after year decade
after decades century by century making
it up
[Laughter]
better and better and a better place
he's like a [ __ ] professor at harvard
he's like yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh all right cool better angels of our
nature better angels of our nature there
we go that's the worst [ __ ] title
i've ever heard it's not good it's not a
good testament i couldn't remember it
you know what's even worse that that's
worse than the [ __ ] the commish
remember that [ __ ] title oh yeah the
commission
michael chiklis michael chuck was a
great actor but was in a show called the
commish michael chiklis has been
between the ages of 40 and 45 for 35
years
it's no good dude
from the makers of the lieutenant
[Laughter]
and sarge
comes the commish
lieutenant
oh [ __ ] from a secret branch in the arm
and the knave
wow i just just finished the goddamn
word [ __ ]
abc or whatever the [ __ ] it was the
community is the commission and we're
gonna call it the commish why not the
commissioner because it's cool you know
what i mean because it's cooler dude
remember when dad made us laugh about
that yeah dude i thought we were kids
that's why we thought the title was so
funny because my dad was [ __ ]
laughing so hard that the show's called
the commish dude
and then do you know what the joke was
that made us die you know what it's you
know when you're laughing really hard
and then somebody says the one thing
that sets you over the edge yeah and you
can't breathe yeah i remember a time
with that for us but go ahead so he said
uh you might as well call it the vomit
oh yeah and and we
[ __ ] died i mean i was like five
years old
you're rolling in
the vomit wow that's right
the vomit killed me
dude they called it the vomit
dude that that would be a horror movie
in the 80s the vomit i mean i'd be much
more likely to watch the vomit oh yeah
remember ours the time that we laughed
so hard was and you peed you actually
peed a little bit
because you were laughing so hard you
told me this oh we were on the way back
from utah driving and we were listening
to that song and we were making fun of
this song about how the guy was killing
it in the music yeah we were laughing so
hard and at the end the [ __ ] after
the crescendo of the song it was fading
out and the guy was killing it and he
just goes oh that's [ __ ] right or
whatever dude the song the song he kept
saying every day every day every day in
the very end he goes every [ __ ]
how do you remember that i laughed so
dude you laughed so hard so did i but
you pissed came out i peed yeah bro we
wear pants
the only time i was an adult i've peed
my pants yeah
yeah i have diapers that i wear
sometimes in the bed and i try to piss
um that's cause you're lazy though yep
it's not because somebody's making you
laugh i know no i know no i don't laugh
at my sleep like really hard that'd be
amazing that'd be great i wish that
would be so good but um and then so i
piss in my diaper and then it it you
can't do depends is [ __ ] honestly
what do you mean depends depends
i know what they are but what do you
mean
they're they're not for heavy ps and i
got the heavy p ones
that's [ __ ] false advertising that
bro i did a heavy pee what i got up dude
the whole bed was so
i mean we almost had to get a new
mattress oh crystal he was like oh [ __ ]
and i was like i thought they work but
why did you do 40. why didn't you just
get up and pee is what i want to know
because i i i when i get anxious when i
go have a lot of anxiety i have to get
up to i realize it's an anxiety thing i
have to get up to pee in the middle of
night too much and i was like [ __ ] this
body i win i got the pens i put them on
i'm like i'm just gonna piss in you and
i did and i [ __ ] it was awful man it
was a travesty i tried it three times
turns out you lose i lose yeah but i
gave it a good [ __ ] college try you
know yeah i don't like them good
good gen good good geriatric pride
hello
[Music]